des types de verre que l'on chauffe
jusqu'à ce qu'il soit aussi malléables
que de la pâte à modeler des gares
suppression que l'on excite avec du très
haut voltage
de la lumière des couleurs et surtout de
l'imagination
depuis trente ans les néons sont le
terrain de jeu des artistes francoual
fred mignot le néon il ya quelque chose
d'extrêmement mystérieux extrêmement
mais le néo même son propre remise et le
mona news il n'y ait en californie où
françois le ferez lignot a déjà exposé
ici sont la ramenèrent voyager à travers
le monde
il affirme que montréal est résolument
qui historiquement une ville non dans
les années 60
montréal était une ville lumineuse
extrêmement éclairé si on pense à la
sainte catherine saint laurent
saint-hubert donc il ya eu des époques
où il y avait de grands supports
d'auvers à montréal les années 90 quand
ça s'est mis à plonger
beaucoup ont pris leur retraite mais
c'est pas mort le néon
c'est en transformation même que je
dirais que j'irais jusqu'à dire une
résurrection
et si le nez on revient on force c'est
pour son côté rétro mais aussi parce que
s'ils se réinventer c'est un médium dont
on n'a pas découvert les limites en
c'est à dire que depuis sa création par
georges claude au début du 20e siècle
ça a beaucoup évolué on sent depuis une
dizaine d'années que le décoratif
prendre grosse part du marché et depuis
4 5 ans c'est vraiment les artistes qui
sont une bonne part du marché
c'est par amour des lignes et des formes
que la toise et sculptrice fanny jane
s'est intéressé à ce médium
mais on ne s'improvise pas souffleur de
verre au chalumeau le néon est un médium
capricieux cet entretien pas cette
pratique le c'est pas du tout comme le
vélo tu l'oubli en fait à chaque fois
presque tous et toutes en commun
brûlures cooper choc électrique c'est
pas nécessairement facile
et d'ailleurs c'est comme je dis souvent
c'est un médium que j'oublie que j'aime
jusqu'à ce que je la lis je les fais là
la récompense est un nouveau souffle
pour le néon un médium sculpté par des
idées brillantes qui nous allume ici
mais bien l'ex andré chartier radio
canada montréal
[Musique]